we have the story though let's talk
about how it's going to hit schools
we got this from fox 12 oregon brown
announces covet 19 vaccine man vaccine
mandate for oregon k-12 teachers and
staff
k-12 school employees in oregon must be
fully vaccinated by the fall and
healthcare workers will no longer be
able to test for covet 19 weekly as a
vaccine alternative so there's a couple
of things here that are big one they
used to say if you get if you don't have
the vaccine you can get a negative test
now that's gone you can't do it
i also don't believe that there are
medical exemptions in any of these
which means teachers who have underlying
condition you're gone wow
so this is uh now affecting our schools
and that means
what's gonna happen are parents gonna
take their kids out of schools some
i mean you you've across the country if
you've seen an uptick in homeschooling
across the board um i think you're going
to see that continue because
again last year
we were all dealing with covet everybody
sort of went through the stages there
was a period of time where people were
sanitizing their groceries when they
came from the store
but now i think we have a better sense
of the the virus we have a better sense
of the tip the different treatment
options
i don't think parents are going to stand
for another year of
distance learning
universal masking mask mandates
vaccine mandates so i think some parents
are going to pull their kids out some
are going to stay and fight
it's interesting that this is oregon i
think their governor just relaxed some
of the graduation requirements in terms
of literacy and numeracy
in the name of equity
again it's always in the name of of
equity and um this doesn't surprise me
in the least bit but it's so curious and
i try not to be a conspiracy theorist
but when you see
the emphasis on our covert response
being basically one of two things
masks and vaccines
where's the discussion of you know
longer term solutions you know diet
exercise
other you know healthier lifestyles
therapeutics different treatment options
it's as if
the elected officials and the
commentators think it's either you wear
your mask you get vaccinated or you're
going to end up in icu and you're going
to die and i feel that's a really bad
way to have this discussion nationally
there was there's a crazy threat on
twitter where some some person claiming
to be a pharmacist i don't know if they
were said that they refused to fill a
prescription for ivermectin
and they didn't know what the
prescription was for
apparently and then they said they
called they called the doctor to verify
and the doctor said you know i'm the
doctor you're the pharmacist you fill it
and again i'll say ivermectin's not fda
approved it's going through studies some
people are optimistic some people aren't
there's studies that say it does nothing
ultimately i just think
what your doctor prescribes man i'm not
going to get in the way of that so so
it's not fda approved go to your doctor
you can talk about what you can do but
to see people on twitter as pharmacists
or at least claiming to be saying that
they would reject any prescription they
disagreed with i was like man didn't we
have this conversation long ago about
birth control
where the pharmacists were like it's
against my religion to give this out so
i'm choosing not to and then they were
yelled at for it
i think if a doctor says he knows what's
best for you i'm not going to get in the
middle of that yeah but these schools
man
to go back to that
i actually think this is a really really
good thing i think the more people we
have homeschooled the better i think
institutionalized learning facilities
are very very bad and so this might
backfire on these these government
institutions in that parents might just
say
what can we do to solve this problem
yeah the school's just getting crazier
and crazier yeah pod learning
you you've heard about like the pods
they do where like you know a bunch of
neighbors will have their kids go to
like one private tutor who will teach
them that sounds brilliant
but you're you're you're a big
homeschool proponent yeah so my wife and
i home school um we had our daughter at
a in a public charter school for about a
year in dc we decided to go in a
different direction
um we love the flexibility that it
offers we love the the
we love the ability to make our home the
center of productive activity
productive economic activity spiritual
activity so you know the ability to
spend quality time with our children
particularly when they're young to pour
into them our values our worldview
and to really teach them because we
believe that education is equal part
scholarship and discipleship
and when you look at the left and some
of the crazy things that go on in
schools i think every parent should ask
themselves do i want these people
discipline my kids um so i think you
know again i'm a huge fan a huge
proponent of home education
for for very principled reasons because
i think this is this is where the right
gets it wrong on school choice right i
believe in school choice
um i think
education is the responsibility of
parents they may
delegate their responsibility to to
schools right in local apprentice but
the schools think and local parents is
spanish you know they think it means
these parents are crazy so it's our turn
to take over as opposed to latin which
means in place of parents
and i think parents need to take
that authority back and they need to
understand that they are in control of
the education process and not and not
the schools and the admins which are
becoming increasingly partisan
from the schools of education that train
teachers
to the actual admins on the local level
down to the the classrooms where
teachers are
expressly saying
we we are
looking to train you know the next
generation of activists and for me when
i look at a lot of these larger urban
school districts that in many respects
honestly are failing our kids and
particularly low-income kids
i'm asking myself you know what's the
point of
you know helping jamal be an activist if
he needs karen to write a sign you know
so to me again as i said this is where
parents can take some control but in
order to do that
we need to talk about other issues and
some of those have to do with family and
family formation my wife and i can do
what we're doing now because we're
married
you're right we have our kids together
we are pulling in the same direction but
homeschooling may be a lot more
difficult for a single mom who's raising
their kids if she has to go out and work
so i think that's where community
institutions can come in um churches or
other you know faith-based institutions
can say
you know we have a couple of educators
on staff you all can bring your kids
here we'll we'll teach them in whatever
curriculum we think is the best and we
can support you know families in that
way churches man
uh i i think a lot of people who might
have you know not grown up with religion
don't understand the power of a church
in in the sense of
you see people and that's really yeah i
mean you go there and then you see your
neighbors
and you know my experience is always
like people would be talking before and
after you needed help with something
people would be there for you yeah some
young men would you know some dad would
be like oh my kids will help you clean
out your garage your boys and they'll be
like yeah and then they'll go and so you
have that community now what do we have
is we have neighbors who never talk to
each other yeah we have this there was
this ad i don't know if it's real i just
saw meme and it's like it's like a new
york subway or something where it says
bad and it shows two faces talking to
each other then it says
uh it says like worse and then it says
better and then it shows two people
wearing masks talking to each other and
then says best and it's two faces
looking down not talking to each other
at all one on a book on the phone and
i'm like
that's a nightmare yeah you know so our
buddy luke who's been on the show quite
a bit he made a video uh a long time ago
on his youtube channel where uh i think
it's called just keep going got nothing
to lose where he said you know he's
lived in new york his whole life and
every day he goes on the train and he
realized that none of these people ever
talked to each other no they would look
at each other so everybody's head is
down so we decided just to start talking
to people and asking them questions
about like what they think and it's like
a really moving video like a million
views and this one back in the day so it
did really really well but that's a
really good example of you know when
when when you're trying to figure out
how to teach your kids
family structure because if you don't
have two parents or someone's a single
mom can't do it she can't afford a tutor
either she might not make it enough
unless she's a single mom and she's got
a really
great job which probably exists in which
case pods
yeah fine you know hire a tutor yeah
have all the kids sit in the classroom
like normal yeah so so i actually um i
wrote an article for the blaze last week
that talked about you know family in
this way it talked about
it actually linked together a story
about nick cannon and his views on
marriage being eurocentric
critical race theory and some of the
crazy stuff going on in schools and then
covet because
imagine you're a woman who's about to
have you know
either you've you've had a child
recently or you're looking to go back to
work
and your employer is saying
you know you have to take the vaccine so
if you're pregnant you're like i don't
know if i want to take it
feeling the pressure to take the vaccine
or lose your job potentially um
that's that's a that's a pretty
difficult decision to make and the point
i was making an article is that
you know when when couples again have
the benefit of marriage where
you know they are
as i said pulling together in the same
direction for their
mutual benefit and the benefit of the
children it gives them options
you know a wife could tell her husband i
i don't want to do this you know i'm
tired of whatever is going on in my
workplace
for one reason or the other and and they
have options that you know other other
families don't have so i was making you
know the case for
marriage as as not just a social good
but also
you know a very sort of practical
arrangement that's not typically how i
make the case about marriage but it also
does have practical benefits and i think
you've seen that during the pandemic and
we have a lot of activists who want to
disrupt that yeah that was one of the
messages from black lives matter tell me
about don't get me started
[Laughter]
i'm trying to get you started on that
like why it seems so destructive yeah to
hurt a family yeah i mean part of it
when at the point where black lives
matter said that we are trained marxists
people should have listened to them
yep i thought you were going to say they
should have shut them out no you're
right they should have listened to them
they should have done that too yeah but
that's why i'm i'm a big believer in
world view
regardless of what it is you should know
what a person believes because that
that'll give you an understanding of why
they believe what they believe
so when marx talks about abolishing the
family because he understood that the
family is not just where children you
know receive their moral instruction but
is also a vehicle for passing on private
property um and he wanted he wanted to
take the kids from
their parents
and
dedicate them to the state right so
black lives matter
you know has a similar vision in in
their black villages principle before
they took it off their website because
they started to get a lot of heat for it
they talked about wanting to disrupt the
nuclear
family requirement that you know
requires mothers to do x y and z
at no point do they talk about
fathers or husbands
um because in their world those people
don't exist and that's why i would make
an argument that you know blm is only
interested in black men to the extent
that their you know dead bodies help
further their political goals and that's
not the type of organization i would
there's there's under no circumstance
what i as a black man get behind any
organization that says that they want to
disrupt the nuclear family at all
they removed it though didn't they take
it off their website they got a lot of
heat but they had their principles on
their website for years
and once they started to grow in
prominence last year and people started
to pick up on it
and and some people would ask them
questions particularly on the
conservative media side
um you now they never got asked
questions from don lemon or roland
martin or any of the other media that
they did you know sort of the corporate
legacy media
but once they started to get those
questions they scrubbed it because they
knew that that was a very very unpopular
take but i think people should
understand
that that organization
you know
those those principles were a reflection
of their world view and that's why i
asked people all the time if you started
an environmental organization and then i
go to your principles and you never
mention the environment that should be a
red flag so when you say you're against
police violence and in your 13
principles
um you never mentioned police violence
men boys
it's all about you know
um being queer affirming transgender
affirming woman affirming
black families in black villages that
erase husbands and and fathers that
should have been a red flag to people
but for whatever reason
you know our our society just they take
whatever the top line is and they run
with it yep corporations yeah they said
hey this is safe let's run with that
yeah and you get a bunch of people
living in new york city who run who work
for advertising firms so they're the
ones who make those decisions yeah yeah
you see how that ended up thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time